hello ladies and gentlemen my name is
Greg and my name is John we're going to
be covering the movie news of the week
from marks 12 through these 1680 can you
see the venom movie lands a 20-18
release date over at sony then a movie
is supposedly not going to be connected
to the MCU oh that's so cute Sony still
trying to matter John Krasinski will be
directing his much more famous wife
Emily Blunt in a supernatural thriller
you know I don't think it's always great
when a Hollywood couple works together
like this yelling Sam Mendes Kate
Winslet and revolutionary road or James
Cameron and linda hamilton and
terminator 2 or Angelina Jolie and Brad
Pitt and by the seat yeah they all lived
happily ever after the release date of
Aquaman has been pushed to December 2018
just in time for Oscar seen moonlight
Henry Cavill has just joined the cast of
mission impossible things now no report
that stated what his role in the film
will be come on man everybody knows
those robots on the big no I don't yeah
you do no I don't think again super
super mad I get that you bb a few baby
too much what it looks like the fly
remake will be directed by JD Dillard
the director of the upcoming film flight
now the fly tells the story of a man
slowly transforming into a man fly
hydrant yes it's open the true story of
Donald Trump ah how does it make sense
Matthew Vaughn is supposedly being eyed
to direct Man of Steel to matthew vaughn
previously directed hit comic book movie
adaptations such a kick ass x-men first
class and Kingsman the Secret Service I
hope they went Matthew Vaughn few what
he does best to create a fun fast-paced
r-rated movie and of course have young
children teenagers committing heinous
acts of violence and it might be a
little too dark though for the DCE use
of be colorful by
fede alvarez will be directing the
sequel to the girl with the dragon
tattoo titled the girl in the spider's
web reports state that he'll be
recasting the oscar-nominated role of
Lisbeth formerly played by a Rooney Mara
insiders state but Natalie Portman and
Scarlett Johansson are in the running to
helm the role if you were my choice I
would go with rebel Wilson why them well
because you know holly was getting a lot
more diverse with its ethnicities and
really supporting feminism I just think
it's about time ups fat people got some
recognition and love to the matrix
reboot or some kind of continuation of
the universe and chip is reportedly in
the works at Warner Brothers the
Wachowskis will reportedly not be
returning for this film I think that if
they do it they should get directors who
have credibility and who can really
breathe new life into a beloved
franchise oh such as like Zack Snyder
yeah or que venir yeah cuz wonderful has
already proved that they can handle the
dce you I'm sure they'll know exactly
what to do with this project next
Christopher Nolan's world war two epic
Dunkirk is reportedly getting a pg-13
rating this is a lot of people concerned
considering it's a war film that will
most likely not depict graphic war
violence yeah we gotta sell those tapes
though yeah thanks again warner brothers
always making them businesses adaptation
of Stephen King's The Dark Tower
releases its first official movie
posters Wow now this looks very
different than a lot of other poachers
yeah I mean there's this ultra dramatic
back shot yeah they're probably lonely
hero and they definitely have some kind
of concealed weapon I'm building and
really getting that gloomy vibes yeah
but those buildings here there's they're
upside down so it's definitely a sone
thing alright well that's it for the
movie news of this week tune in next
week will be more movie news of the week
of that week of the week cuz you've
already heard movie news on Greg Alva
subscribe to the real rejects John
Reeves the Jerry on Twitter and
Instagram social media manager of Blum
the real reject click that notification
bell click it click the belt